[Bram] An eldwyrm dug this.
Asleep.
How do you know?
We're not dead.
Asleep, then.
Lovely.
Now is our chance. Now we kill the beast.
No. Now we pray he doesn't wake up.
[ominous music]
[whistle in distance]
[swoosh]
-[Sagan mewls]
-[Davion] What was that?
Dinner.
[leaves rustling]
[crackling]
The only people I've ever seen shoot
that well have points on their ears.
[sighs]
You're right. I should sleep on it.
I'll talk to Davion in the morning,
he'll understand, he'll listen.
-[Marci snoring]
-[sighs]
Thank you, Marci.
You always know exactly what to say.
[tranquil music]
[grunting and growling]
[growling]
[grunts]
[snarls]
[dreamy music]
[Mirana] You?
We have a better offer
than a few trinkets and empty promises.
May I introduce Mirana,
once Princess of the Moon,
once Princess of the Sun, and now…
princess of nothing at all.
I locate precious things
for wealthy people.
One of my clients happens to be
from the Helio Imperium.
Your uncle.
And he wants you so very badly.
I should have let
those villagers kill you.
Probably.
The mute is yours.
Take them downstairs.
[ominous music]
Do you love me?
You are the light
that shines behind my eyes.
Mm, worship me.
No one will worship you more.
[breathes deeply]
Do you love me?
[gasps]
Save me! Please, Goddess!
Do you love me?
Goddess, please!
[pants]
I love you!
Please!
[screams]
[dreamy music]
You fought well.
You honor me.
As you honor me.
[grunts]
[gasps]
[choking gasps]
[tinkles]
[gasps]
[Luna] We know what you want.
The return of your Dark Lady, Mene.
Mene, who would plunge the world
in endless shadow.
-[gasps]
-[Luna] Not today.
Give me the lotuses,
or I send all of you
back to her dead embrace.
We… We don't have them. They're gone.
-[grunts]
-[shrieks]
What… What have you done?
What have you done?
-The lotuses. Now.
-Stop. Please. I don't have them.
Lying. Unwise.
[panting]
[both grunts]
[body thuds]